health officials in Minnesota are
tackling the worst measles outbreak in
nearly 30 years most of those with the
disease are unvaccinated Somali American
children Minnesota has a largest Somali
population in this country the state's
health commissioner says the community
has been targeted with misinformation
about vaccine risk Jamie yuccas is at
Children's Hospital at Children's
Minnesota hospital and she joins us now
with the story Jamie good morning good
morning here at Children's Minnesota
doctors have treated 34 of the 48
confirmed cases when patients visit
they're given a mask to cover up that's
because the virus is so contagious that
if you're exposed to it and you don't
have the vaccine there's a 90% chance
you'll contract it
have you gone a day without having a new
case we have gone a zero days without
having a new case Patsy stinchfield is
the director for infection control at
Children's Minnesota Hospital she says
the measles outbreak started about four
weeks ago 46 of the 48 confirmed cases
are in children ten years old or younger
I just finished doing rounds on these
children and they are miserable they're
in the hospital they have IVs they're
not drinking they have terrible cough
some have pneumonia the measles virus
commonly travels through the air where
it can live for up to two hours making
it more contagious than the flu the only
vaccine available in the u.s. to prevent
the spread of the disease is the measles
mumps and rubella vaccine or MMR one in
a thousand children who get measles will
have encephalitis or infection in their
brain they can have permanent brain
damage they can have blindness or
deafness and so we wouldn't vaccinate if
this was just a Raschi illness this is a
very serious disease in 2014 almost 90%
of two-year-old Minnesota children were
vaccinated against measles in the Somali
community that number plummeted to about
40 percent community leader Abdul Razak
bee he says it's because of an unfounded
fear spawned by anti vaccine activists
that MMR causes autism some parents they
said at least this
curable because they believe that thing
is causing autism and they don't have a
choice ikura Muhammad is a Somali
American mother of five children four
have received the MMR vaccine but she
waited until they were older even after
getting measles herself what was that
like a lot of hospital stay Mohamed
doesn't plan to vaccinate her
five-year-old until he starts school in
the fall there is this big decision to
make you know are you going to choose to
take the risk to vaccinate and get this
long-term chronic illness or are you
going to take the risk of trying to do
everything that you can in your power to
prevent your child from getting your
measles that's a very hard toys doctors
say false information linking vaccines
to autism is hurting children do you get
frustrated that this misinformation
still is out there it is frustrating
because we know these diseases are
contagious they can spread they can take
children's lives and all we have to do
is go back to before we had vaccines
where United States had four million
cases of measles and we will go back
there if we don't continue to vaccinate
scientific studies show there is no
direct correlation between the MMR
vaccine and an increased risk in autism
even in children who are at increased
risk for the disorder now here in
Minnesota health officials say it could
take months for this epidemic to be over
that's because they need at least six
weeks with no new reported cases of
measles for the outbreak to be
considered finished Gail all right Thank
You Jamie good information there thanks
a lot